the monkey pox virus is a growing
concern for parents as kids go back to
school health officials in Harris County
Texas say a presumptive positive case
there could mean that now at least seven
children in these United States have now
tested positive for monkey pox that
child in Texas is expected to make a
full recovery by the way in all adults
and kids there are now nearly 13 000
monkey pox cases Nationwide for more on
all of it Dr David Aegis joins us now uh
Dr Aegis good morning monkey pox kids
what's your level of concern
um Good morning Tony so I want parents
not to worry but to be aware and I think
that's what's critical so monkey pox is
only spread when you touch a rash and so
it's not really spread through the air
or through surfaces well and so the key
is is that if you or your child have a
rash if it's a a rash you need to go to
your doctor and to get that swabbed and
tested if it's an unexplained rash and I
think that's critical and we will stop
it but when you look at the cases
globally 99 are in adult men and 97
percent are in men who have sex with men
so children it is remarkably rare
that's good to hear uh for parents and
teachers who are concerned what common
sense steps can they take to help
protect kids
well common sense is again anybody who
has a rash keeps saying make sure you do
not come to school with that rash and if
it's unexplained there's no cause for it
it should be tested but washing hands
you know when children finish the play
period they should all go and they can
wash their hands and we can dramatically
stop any risk of spread that simple
washing in the hands as we said with
every viral outbreak has a major role
Dr Aegis the first case of polio in a
decade was confirmed here in New York
City found in the City Water waste
should we be concerned about this
yeah Nate it is really concerning I mean
because this is the first symptomatic
case of a person who developed paralysis
a young adult from poly who was
unvaccinated and there are parts of the
country where vaccination rates in young
kids is 60 70 percent whereas it really
needs to be in the high 90 percent range
and when there's one case of paralysis
which means there are probably hundreds
of cases of polios in those underlying
regions so we have to push for these
vaccines which work
so if we're not vaccinated against polio
then that is concerning when it comes to
this
yeah you could set it is that yes is
that when you're not vaccinating for
polio this virus can cause paralysis and
serious ramifications and the vaccine
Campaign which began in the 50s was
remarkably successful and it worked
although now we're seeing it come back
because some counties in this country
have a very low vaccination rate for a
number of reasons we have to Target
those counties and get vaccines in arms
of young children and then this will not
be concerned but it's happening now in
Britain it's happening in Israel and
it's happening here in the United States
Dr David agus thank you for this
valuable information